[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i want to take you through a
little bit of a tangent
stemming from one of the games that
happened at the
recent grand chess tour paris event of
course wesley's so with jesus on his
side
is our champion this year and uh of
course he played a lot of really
interesting games
and if we have time i want to take a
look at some of them but first i want to
actually take you through this game
between maxine vashila grav who had a
very roller coaster tournament a lot of
ups and downs
but ended up in the top half of the
field against alireza for ruja also
finishing in the top half of the field
and this was actually one of the blitz
games so
definitely some back and forth but let's
just jump into it here
and see where this game takes us we get
e4
c5 knight f3 knight c6 and ac3 sicilian
so of course these sicilians have a
reputation for being a bit less
interesting a bit less
um uh combative than the open sicilian
but definitely something to uh
you know take seriously we get knight f6
by black
now e5 knight d5 and we do this little
dance
with the black knight coming over to b6
and
after bishop to b3 at first glance it
looks
like white is going to be fighting for a
pretty serious opening advantage right
the
move d4 is definitely uh on tap
and if white is able to get this move
you know let's say black plays some
slower move
like e6 here white can play d4
and you would get some you know french
kind of looking positions where white
does have this nice space
edge in the center now that's not to say
that black is
doing badly here by any means but white
would have sort of something to play for
out of the opening
so instead we see uh ali rezafaruja
adopting a slightly safer move here in
the form of c4
and this is why the c3 sicilian really
isn't going to be
quite so uh fearsome with this pawn on
c4
of course white can never place this
pawn on d4 comfortably
without black being able to take on
passant and
shattering white's big space advantage
in the center
to follow up black plays d5 staking his
own claim in the center
we get a trade of these pawns white
castles
g6 and then here mvl actually
pulls out a pretty interesting idea i
think the main moves here are b3
trying to get rid of this pawn or d4
just accepting this trade
and going down a slightly simpler
territory
but instead we're actually going to see
uh white
go with uh a4 here and i'm sorry knight
a3 is also a move that can
come commonly be played instead though
mvl plays a4 which is much less common
and mdl's point as we'll see is that
after simple development
he's playing a5 and kicking this knight
off the b6 square
the game continued with knight d5 and
then
mvl plays a move that uh sort of
surprises me to be honest
so with this a4a5 plan i would have
thought that he was
trying to find some way to go after this
pawn on c4
unfortunately it's kind of tough to do
that i'd love to play knight a3 but now
that actually
hangs the pawn something like queen e2
doesn't feel
quite right stepping into potential
knight f4 ideas
so maybe there just simply wasn't a good
way to do it and that's why we see
mvl play this move d3
now though this pawn on a5 doesn't seem
quite as useful you know it drove this
knight into the center
but this knight isn't exactly doing
badly on d5 so definitely i think
alireza getting a good position here out
of the opening
and he's able to simply take on d3
bishop d3 and castles
now mvl does try to make use of this
pawn to apply a little bit of pressure
on the long on the long diagonal but we
see rook d8
knight a3 and knight takes c3
is a tactic that uh mvl i think quite
simply missed
uh so uh alireza is actually going up
a free pawn here but that's not what i'm
interested in talking about
right this was just a tactic that i
think wasn't on mvl's radar of course if
we trade the queens
alireza has this nice inner meso
checking the king removing the knight
from the threat of capture
and this knight's escape route is always
going to be through the c1 square
before white can ever really think about
trapping it
this is actually what happens in the
game there's really no other choice here
for you know for white you can't take
the knight because the queen's hanging
and so we get
this line or takes d6 and now knight b5
is mvl's choice he's sort of going for
broke now on the queen side
with this a6 idea but here actually
ali reza missed his chance to
consolidate his advantage
and walk away with you know probably a
win
and his position is very very good here
so black to move in this position chat i
want to see if you guys can find
the tactical resource that alireza
missed to
secure his advantage
and while you're thinking about that i
just want to talk a little bit about
mvl's last few moves you'll notice that
he hung the pawn
and then played very very immediately
and that's
a good practical thing to do uh not only
in your blitz games but in
actual tournament games as well and the
reason for that
is whenever you are the side capturing
extra material in this case it was just
a pawn but it's still extra material
you always have to spend a little bit of
time to do that in this case
you know black lost a few tempe putting
this knight on e2
and then you know capturing back on d6
and moving the rook back as well so
black
definitely spent time to capture this
pawn so
quite often you'll see that if you're
going to get some concrete compensation
for your material
it has to sort of happen right away you
have to make use of that extra time your
opponent spent
you know uh turn your sacrifices
or turn your uh you know blunders into
sacrifices right make use of that extra
time
try to put on some pressure so that's
what mvl does here it's a good practical
decision
but of course there is a tactical
resource to
take him out of the game and as i reload
the chat so that it actually works now
i'm not seeing the correct answer just
yet
these moves like knight d4 aren't quite
right uh mbl's
threat of a takes b7 is going to be
pretty real here
to show you what happened in the game
ferugia kept things simple and played
rook b8
but this is a little bit too slow it
allowed mvl
to get the counter play he wanted
knight takes bishop and then bishop
takes b2 so this is actually a pretty
good idea
and it would i think
at least keep the balance here but
bishop takes b2 might actually be a
little bit much you have to move this
guy again
and then uh you'll see that perhaps
there are more threats here than you
gave white credit for
but taking on c1 definitely wouldn't
spoil anything
but there's something even better in
this position
so it's pretty understandable that
ferugia missed it because it's not
exactly an intuitive move
but you'll notice that this pawn
would be hanging if not for the fact
that this bishop is attacking this
knight on c6
and it turns out the best way to
continue here is to simply make the
bishop move off of e4
and then this kind of becomes an
impossible thing for
uh you know for for white to deal with
uh you have to move this bishop if you
move it back to c2
i'm simply going to take on a6 and now
knight c7 or b8
isn't really giving you anything and
this is going to be a rather
sad position now especially with knight
b4 coming in at the end
um so after f5 the best that white can
do is to take on c6
and now after b takes c6 you get um
knight to c7 we can actually insert this
but even simpler it's just moving the
work out of the way
saving the knight and then mvl's
short-lived
tactical foray winds up empty-handed
now in the game alyreza misses this f5
idea and instead plays rook b8 and now
simply bishop e3 by white
and you see that black perhaps hasn't
really had time
to solve the problems with this slow
move rick ba definitely i think at the
very least black should have taken on c1
before playing rook b8 now after knight
d4
it's actually mvl who's going to wind up
on the better side of things here after
the simple takes takes
and rook fd1 would have been best
instead we get this
move bishop f4 and still a solid
advantage for white
just to briefly show you though the idea
here is that you don't
really want to move this knight number
one because of this pin
but also very very importantly is the
pin on the a7 pawn if you were to play
something like 96 which you might have
to we would get takes takes
and bishop takes a7 and from here
black is going to be in a lot of trouble
even something simple like
bishop b6 knight c6 for example
take take and a7 and this pawn is just
simply way too far advanced
and black is probably busted um
but that wasn't played instead we get
bishop f4 going after the rook on b8
pawn to e5 and mvl regains the pawn
and has a lot more space in this
position and because of that space
he's able to make this threat against
the rook and actually immediately win
an exchange so here we see the rook on
b8 is attacked the rook moves you're
going to run into a takes b7 and just be
totally busted
and that is how we arrive at our end
game of choice here tonight
just fast forwarding a little bit mvl
does some fancy footwork
trading one advantage for another in
this case the very far advanced a6 pawn
and then faruja is forced to give back
the rook on a8 here and we wind up
in this end game and this is what i want
to talk about
uh for the first part of tonight's
lecture i don't know if it'll take us
the full hour
if not we're going to go over some more
games from paris
but end games of this nature end games
where
one side has the rook and the other side
has the knight
are they winning how often are they
winning what does it take
to hold these positions and so i want to
pause here for just a moment
and ask the chat room what they think
about this particular end game does
black have holding chances
should white be winning what's going on
here what do we think
black has time trouble in this position
yeah njf
has the right idea if you guys watched
last week
you'll all know the position on the
clock beats the position on the board
in many many cases but we're just
talking about the chess here
ignoring the time trouble ignoring the
time trouble
raphael says white is better but this is
drawable
shailesh says a billionaire can win this
with black i'm not going to name any
names but
i think you might have might there
there might be something to that
especially in blitz
bjorn says black has holding chances
because of the king's activity
so yeah that's really going to be the uh
the thing here is can black
uh hold the position because the pieces
are so active because black has this
extra pawn
so let me ask you a question now
if you were to take this pawn off the
board if there were no pawn on b5
what do we think is it hopeless is white
winning is
black going to hold it's going on there
just lift this guy off the board and
what happens then
if you lift this b-pawn off the board
is black able to ever hold this
bjorn says then white is winning and
yeah
that's uh my feel for the position as
well
in general most three v3s on one side of
the board
uh the rook is going to be able to
outmaneuver the knight and
win without too much difficulty so the
real question here
is can white win this pawn on b5
what does black need to try to do to
keep that from happening to keep this
pawn
alive and what should white do
in order to to win this pawn what do we
think
and you might be thinking you know
aren't aren't these questions sort of
for a later date why bother thinking
about all of this
right away
why not think about it later but we'll
see that white's next move
might actually be very very important
ron says attack the defender right okay
so we need to make the knight move out
of the way
and then take the pawn but the thing to
realize is that the rook alone is not
going to be enough
to uh to get this done it's not like you
can magically teleport this guy to b6
and uh even if you could you know play
like rook a6
knight moves or you know right b6
obviously isn't playable there
if we play rook b8 i'm going to bring my
king in and you attacking my knight
isn't really going to do it so
tactically black is holding on to the
pawn
against just the rook for the moment so
you of course
need to bring in the king as well
so with all of this stuff in mind uh
what is the best move
for white here we sort of have our feel
for the position
you know we expect that if we can get
this b-pawn off the board we're going to
be winning with whites
if the b-pawn is on the board maybe it's
going to be a little bit tougher
so as white here you know combining all
of these ideas
realizing black is going to try to hold
on to this knights
and pawn what is the best move
in this position
okay ricardo says f3 dylan says rook a5
carter says rook b8 king f6 rook b6 king
e5 okay so that was the line i
i had showed we got f4 for white
king g1
all right so far no one is playing the
best move and no one is playing like mvl
either tough
h4 is not quite right
ahmet says prevent the king and yeah
that's going to lead us to the right
idea
i think practically the best move the
easiest to understand
is rook a6 here now why is rook a6 the
best move
because after knight to c4 were able to
block the king's access
into the game and now that we've blocked
the king we
are free to bring in our own king here
notably we're not really going to be
afraid of
black ever playing something like b4
number one
tactically it just loses the pawn to
rook a4 but even if it didn't
um you know just because this pawn is
further up the board doesn't mean that's
actually going to be
all that more advantageous for
uh you know for for black now why is
that well it's because it's harder to
set up this
kind of blockade where you're defending
the knight in the pawn and holding
everything together you know white's
going to get or black's going to get
stretched a little bit thin
so something like kg1 here would have
been
really nice and now unfortunately with
black it's really tough to bring your
king in you might even have to try to go
this way
and it's just going to be way too slow
right we bring our king to e2
let's say something like king f5 and now
all of a sudden
we're just immediately coming after your
pawn
you know king d3 for example and it's
pretty clear here
that white is going to be winning right
we can
at the very least do this take this pawn
and call it a day so i think this would
have been the best way to continue for
mvl mvl actually chose a different route
with rook to d8
which i don't think spoils anything just
yet um but after rook d5
i really don't like the way he uh
chose to handle this position so rook d5
again i don't think spoils anything the
knight goes to a3 now to defend the pawn
but here i really would have liked to
see the move rook to d6 with the exact
same idea we just looked at
instead though we see king g1 and now
we're going to see
that white's life is going to be
significantly harder
as ali reza tries to construct some kind
of fortress
so we bring king f6 king f1 king e6
now this rook has to move we get knight
c4
rook d8 black plays this move h5
which is always a good idea usually this
is the most solid setup you can go for
really in rook end games and rook versus
night end games even in rook versus
bishop end games
this seems to be the best way to kind of
keep your pawns all together
in this kind of line rook b8 and now
knight d6
and we've got a pretty different
position compared to the ones we were
looking
at with the rook on a6 in this case now
uh black has successfully
sort of put the onus back onto white you
know black saying
i've got this pawn defended i've got
this pawn defended i've got this knight
defended
how are you going to break uh break my
my position here
and so that's the question uh well let's
play a couple more obvious moves first
we want to bring our king in as far as
possible
black's going to play king d5 and we
sort of see now
the uh the little little fortress that
we've got going on with black we're
gonna
guard the entry points with our king and
see what we can
what we can do from there so king to d3
and now chat room i want you guys to try
and find
the best idea here for whites and the
best idea for
for black in response so let's start
with white how are we going to try to
break this fortress how are we going to
try to invade
and win this b-pawn what can we do
what can we do to break this fortress
how can you possibly make any progress
here with
white
gruen says a pawn break and in this case
that's actually going to be the wrong
idea
so it's pretty tough to make a past pawn
in a three versus three especially
against this nice solid setup by
black and so any pawn trait is actually
giving
uh you know black more opportunities to
to get closer to
a draw you know obviously if all the
pawns disappear then we have a draw
it's not like you have a pawn break to
make a past pawn
you don't even really have a pawn break
to make a weakness in black's position
ahmed says king c5 and then win the
opposition so okay
we get king c5 king c3
and what if i just check you
okay i can actually take your pawn so
let's go forward then
obviously mvl notices this threat this
is actually played in the game so we get
f3
now king d5 it's pretty easy to win the
opposition here
you uh you just pass so congratulations
you've won the opposition
now it's black's turn black's gonna play
another move
so what are you doing how are you making
any progress
how are you making progress here
h4 says turkey h4 is a good way to lose
a pawn
with white h4 i might attack that guy
and win your pawn be careful
and jf says g4 and again these kinds of
pawn breaks are a little bit dangerous
with white if you
play something like g4 i might just take
it play king f4
and all of a sudden you're out of ponds
right
there's not that many pawns left it
can't be offering pawn traits
and wow ricardo actually has a great
idea
so as always with a knight a big
problem that you run into is the
inability to waste a tempo so when you
have the more powerful piece like the
rook against the knight
and this actually goes in many other end
games
a very very common idea is to try to put
the opponent into
zouzwan so for example
if we can take away all of black's
passing moves
then we actually have a very nice shot
at uh
you know putting black into zugsvan
ziggsvong and
winning the game so let's see how mvl
goes about doing that ricardo had the
idea potentially play
f4 to take away this e5 square and that
is definitely an
important part of it but let's see what
else mvl does so first he goes rook a1
we see the king come back to d5 now rook
e1 taking away the e5 square in a
slightly different way
black passes with knight c4 get rookie 7
and now al reza actually
willingly breaks from his fortress but
i'm interested
in what would happen if we saw uh
you know alareza sort of stick to his
guns here
so what would we do with white in this
position
to try and make progress
but if f4 just takes so yeah we're not
playing f4 with the black king on e5
we're doing it's uh doing it perhaps
here
perhaps
audi says it's a draw so i sort of
spoiled it here but i think f4 is a
great idea
uh to make progress in this position
because now
black is gonna be forced to make a
weakness uh
to to keep the work out of e5 and if you
can't keep the rook out of e5
then well let's say you don't play h4
let's just say king c6
uh or king c5 of course you're gonna get
matt with rooks ricky five check
king c6 and now all of a sudden uh white
is
able to progress either through c3 and
b4
or really any other way let's say king
c3 for example
something like knight c4 or k7 knight d6
king b4 and all of a sudden you see that
white's king is definitely invading
you can also bring the king in through
d4 as well
but this is definitely a way that mvl
could have tried to make progress now
i think eloreza perhaps still should
have gone for this
but maybe black can do even better uh
in a position like this so we've seen
white's idea to potentially make
progress
in a longer time control game you know
you can sort of think through that a
little bit more clearly
so now knowing white's plan to make
progress he's going to try to put us
in zugsvang take away all of our passing
moves what can we do
as black to try and prevent it
what can we do here
how can we make our fortress a little
bit more solid
so the idea you should be looking for is
to
somehow prevent you know white from
playing this f4
and rookie 5 idea and so yeah ahmet
again is coming in
with a good idea in the form of this
move g5
now unfortunately g5 is actually a
slight bit premature
because white is able to play this move
g3 right away and now the issue
is that if you sort of continue with
your passing plan
well number one you're going to run into
rook h8 that i guess that's that's
number one
and if you try to solve this problem
with h4 then white is able to capture
so the accurate way to do it is to
actually play this move h4
first now with the idea of continuing
through
with g5 so let's say white continues
like in the game
now we're going to play this nice move
g5
and it's going to be very very difficult
to break this
fortress right if you want to play g3
i'm going to take if you want to play f4
i'm going to take and then you simply
don't have enough pawns left to
win the game much less break down my
fortress
so i think this h4 g5 f6 idea could have
been really cool
um and the reason why i take you through
this sort of
uh in this process you know black
building the fortress
white finding some way to break through
and then black going back and finding
the improvement for black
is this is a really good idea to think
about your end games
in slower time control games right you
don't want to just be thinking about
some you know good setup for yourself
you want to be thinking about how your
opponent is going to try to break that
setup
and uh you know far in advance finding
ways
to make that difficult so in this case i
think this
would have actually just been a drawn
position i really have no idea
how white is ever going to break through
this and i i think black has very very
good holding chances
in this position uh instead though let's
go back to the game
we see f3 by whites and actually in this
position
um after rookie seven uh ali reza
voluntarily
sort of broke his own fortress here
again i think this knight d6 idea
still would have made life very very
difficult for white instead though
we get king d6 taking advantage of this
nice tactical idea so rook a7 was played
instead
and now after 95 check black is simply
unable to to hold on to this pawn this
knight's been
forced out of position it wasn't too
late to go back to king d5 with the idea
of knight d6
but after 95 check i think white is just
picking up this pawn
but that's not the whole story so rook
b7
and yes in fact the b7 pawn was not long
for this world
alireza goes for knight e3 we see g3
in the game and then alareza uh
decides to go for something a little bit
more interesting he could have just
played something like knight f5
and waited for you know the the slow
the slow painful death but instead he
went for h4
trying to break up white's pawns and uh
white actually just can capture here and
after knight f5
go h5 gh5
and i'm going to show you a couple more
moves and then ask you
a pretty fun question here so black
brings the king to the king side
white also brings the king in
we get a little shuffle shuffle f6 98
and now knight g7 and my question for
you is
what does this remind you of it should
remind you of a pretty famous game
from a tournament that was very recently
played a pretty important tournament
where this knight g7 idea was actually
missed
by none other than maxine vashir lagrave
mvl had the chance to draw a very
important game
by building a fortress with the knight
on g7 but he missed it in that game
who knows what i'm talking about oh
chess bunzo quick on the draw here with
the fabi mvl
so of course this knight g7 idea can be
a very nice
way to build a fortress here
guarding every entry point aside from e7
and the point is
that e7 can also be guarded by the king
or
alternatively if the king were to wander
too far away
into the e7 square then black can start
going for count to play right bringing
his own king out and using the knight to
attack the pawns
and things like that so what's the
difference
from this position compared to fobby's
position against
mvl well we can actually take a quick
look at it here i've got it right over
hopefully i'm not making ben too angry
with my changes
but uh this position was where knight g7
should have been played
so obviously what's different from that
last position
to this position well there is an extra
pawn
on the board and that's going to change
a lot here so jumping back
to the position we have in this game uh
why is the extra pawn so so important
well number one if we keep everything on
the board we're going to be able to
maneuver around
and make more threats than normal but
more importantly there is a very
specific
tactical resource that white can always
rely on in these positions
and i'm hoping you guys are able to find
it here so white to move
and end the game basically white to move
and end the game
how do you just end the game on the spot
as mvl
yeah chess bunzo with the right idea
with two pawns on the board
the king and pawn end games more often
than not
have a lot higher chance of being
decisive so simply rook g1 check
and the tactical resource that black has
to look out for is simply
uh well simplifying into the king and
pawn end game and after king g7
king f5 spawn on f6 is going to drop
and white is going to be totally winning
you play king f7 for example then h4
and you have to pick a side with your
king f4
f5 and you are busted here
now picture if these two pawns were gone
then obviously this position
is a draw and that's why having an extra
pawn on the board is actually really
really bad for black
that's why you need to be so careful
about how many pawn trades you allow
with the white pieces the fewer pawns
there are the easier it is
for the knight to hold and so mvl does
go on to win this game
ally rezat chose not to play king f7
instead going h4
but now the pawn on h4 drops and
i think they played on for quite a ways
with this
nice little subtlety here blocking the
king out can't take otherwise i promote
and here after f5 king e3
i believe ali reza resigned but uh as
always there's some fun dgt quirks
when the kings are near the center of
the board and the game ends so according
to dgt the game didn't end here
uh black played king d5 and then white
played kingy for
check and that made alireza resign
far too strong king e4 check
some would say double check but they
they would be wrong
um so what can we learn from this game
well
this huge thinking process about
building your your fortress in these
rook versus night end games
is really really helpful um find
the best way to pose a problem for your
opponent then you try to think
can my opponent break through this
fortress somehow and if so
well you try to find some way to prevent
it alorezo wasn't able to do it in this
game
of course it was a blitz game he had 11
seconds on his clock hard to blame him
but now i want to jump to a game where
uh perhaps white uh has no excuse
for not being able to find the way to
hold
and that's going to be a game between
milan vidmar
and alexander alekhine so this is
actually a game that gets featured
in doveretsky's endgame manual and i
want to talk about a little bit
we're actually just going to jump
straight to the end game
because i said so uh so knight e4
h6 and this is the position where i want
to start so of course
it's a little bit better than a three
versus three
uh down the exchange in this case white
has an extra pawn so with the extra pawn
you would really assume white has some
way to hold
and you would be correct in this case
but
i'm curious if you guys can come up with
a good formation for whites
to try and hold this game what would you
go for here
with the white pieces
what can we do with the white pieces
can't you just move your knight around
well we're going to look at what happens
if you just move the knight around
so games 2012 has one idea one
good feature in the position is this
move h5 it's definitely something
that should be very carefully considered
though uh we'll see that white plays h5
in the game
and perhaps this works out not so well
for him
in the long haul
audi says something quiet like king h3
so you guys are
you know going at this um with specific
moves which is okay that's
usually how it works in these kinds of
lectures but i want to i want you to
take a slightly different approach think
of
this position the way we were thinking
of mvl versus
ali reza right you want to find a
fortress you want to find a setup for
your pieces that would be
ideal see if you can achieve it and uh
you know make it so that your opponent
can't break through so we don't want
just one move here we want to find
some way to organize our pieces some
plan to organize our
uh to be able to hold this game so what
are you looking for
in your your ideal fortress what do you
want
and wow hello to anesu watching from
zimbabwe
all right and i say this and all i get
is single moves in the chat
all right general gaming has a fortress
idea he wants to make a fortress with
f3 g4 g5
and knight g2 that would be
a strange fortress in my opinion i guess
going for this knight g2 idea
that we've seen from fabi's game and uh
not working in ali reza's game but no
that one's a little bit strange we'll
take a look at it
but seems a little bit strange
all right well let's take a look at what
happened in the game
we'll see if this can give you guys a
little bit more of a clear idea
of what we're trying to do with white so
this is what white played in the game
obviously didn't go so well for him so
white tried this idea
you know i shouldn't be in any danger
i'm just going to shuffle my knight
around
knight f2 knight d3 knight f4
knight back to d3 knight back to f2
knight h3 king e5 and here
uh white actually plays this this move
h5
that you guys were discussing in the
chat so i mentioned that this is really
a double-edged move right you want to
well i guess keep the rook out of g6 but
also immobilize these pawns
but by moving the pawn another inch up
the board
it is going to be a little bit further
away from
its defenders right it's a little bit
tougher to defend the pawn one is to
square up the board and alkyne is able
to make use of this idea
with rook c2 and some more maneuvering
number one to attack this pawn on h5 and
at the same time
make threats of coming in to attack
behind white's king attack the g2 pawn
as well going after both weaknesses
so in the game white actually comes up
with a pretty clever resource
to keep both things under wraps here of
course this
pawn on g7 is hanging you can't capture
it because
this would be unfortunate so white comes
up with this move f4 and this is really
the only move to stay in the game so you
stop rook g5
and now if rook takes h5 you would take
on g7 and still be holding the position
now alekhine simply plants this rook on
f5 and seemingly out of nowhere
white has a lot of problems to solve if
you play knight tx g7
you're gonna run into rook takes f4 and
this is not going to be very easy
to hold in fact objectively this
position is simply lost
this pawn in h5 is going to be weak the
knight is
not placed very well and you're nowhere
near setting up some kind of defensive
fortress right
you're just no you're nowhere near being
able to do that your pieces are
scattered across the board in the game
white tries king g4 which is a good try
this rick steps back to f6
and now white plays this move e5
uh in the game we see rook f7 by alkyne
perhaps rookie four
was a slightly better idea uh
of course if you take on g7 rick f7
knight e6 rook takes f5 and this is
going to be very very similar to what we
just looked at white's pieces are a
little bit more organized
but still it's not going to be enough to
to hold the game
you're going to have to move the knight
and rook g5 check and you're kind of
getting getting checkmated right away
instead though alakan defends his pawn
we see g3 king e4 and now
white is simply busted the pawn on e4
disappears
and i think in this position actually or
perhaps it was this position uh white
ends up resigning just gives up the game
the pawn on f5 is falling and you know
white is nowhere near setting up a
fortress
so some of you guys were wondering how
you can possibly lose this well that's
how you can possibly lose this right
black
makes threats here makes threats there
and as you
move up the board you make more
weaknesses the next thing you know you
can't defend all your pieces
and black is winning so that's what
happens
if you sort of go into it without a plan
right light was just sort of haphazardly
moving
plays this h5 move which gives black
something to target
and then next thing you know uh black's
threatening to invade over here
black's threatening to take over here
and you have to start playing some very
scary moves in order to stay in the game
so much better to start thinking
uh in the initial position of the end
game
rather than start thinking when things
are already very very scary
so what we don't want to do is get drawn
into this game of
you know having to respond to threats
and having black you know always
on the verge of winning right we don't
want to rely on
you know some flimsy tactical resource
to keep us in the game
so what can we do what's our ideal setup
why not knight takes g7 so i mentioned
once or twice
you don't want to hang a fork i think in
most of those positions
alekhine's idea was rook g5 attacking
both things at the same time
and everybody's got a different setup i
like moroccan
outlaws pawn structure the best actually
and games 2012
agrees so our ideal setup is obviously
going to be one where we really only
have
one weakness so as in the mvl
foruga game the best setup is going to
be with your pawns in a line from f3
to h5 like this sort of building out
towards the edge of the board
that's going to be a very very common
theme kind of throughout
really any end game so the question is
how can we go about building it and the
question is why are other things worse
so i saw this be mentioned in the game
and i'll just i'll just let you do it
for free
everything you want here um obviously
no guarantee that uh black doesn't have
better here
but i saw someone saying you know i want
the knight on f2 and f4 g3 h4
so you know is this going to be sort of
a robust fortress unfortunately
i don't really think it is um your king
is going to be a little bit airy
and you can already envision you know
black trying to invade over here and
it's going to be tough
to to keep them out so why is this
fortress
not so good well it's because this
knight is in a purely defensive
role so not only do we want to set up
this f3 g4
h5 idea but we also want the knight
doing two things at once you know the
knight is a short range piece
but as the pawns are on the same side of
the board we are able to use it for
multiple purposes so of course the ideal
thing to do
with our knight is to both defend the
invasion squares
and also attack our opponent's pawns
and with these two things together it's
actually very very easy
to hold the draw in this case so that's
the key idea
you need to take away in these rook
versus night end games try
to use your knight both as a defender
and an attacker
with the pawns on the same side of the
board like this and more often than not
it's safer to rely on the knight's
attacking abilities than defensive
abilities like i mentioned
in mvl versus uh ferugia it's very easy
to get put into zugsvang
with the knight and so using it purely
defensively
can very very often go wrong for you so
let's see
what the best move in this position is
we know what our setup
wants to be we want h3 g4 h5 what's the
best way of doing it
well i don't really love playing h5
directly again this pawn's a little bit
lonely out there on h5
so the best move in my opinion is king
h3
as some people in the chat are arriving
at you want to play king h3
because you want to play g4 and h5
right so king h3 i think is the best
move
and now let's say black just naively
maneuvers with the king we're going to
play g4
king g3
and h5 so okay let's say black plays
something like rook a2 if you check me i
simply play this that's no danger at all
let's say rook a2
now what do we want to do where do we
want to put our knight
where do we want to put our knight
where should we try to put the knights
so yeah we would love to put it onto the
f5 square this is
just going to be far and away the best
square
for the night so it's actually a little
bit tough to achieve here but the good
news is
it's only tough to achieve because our
opponent's king is sort of out front
here
guarding this this d6 square so the only
way
for black to make any threats here of
course is to come attack the f3 pawn
and as soon as black tries to do that we
are immediately going to plant this guy
onto onto f5 for the moment though play
something like
knight to f2 say
okay let's not hang the fork let's say
i don't know black plays like rook a4 or
something you know i can come back to e4
and also just play knight h3
and if given the chance i'll even play
knight f4
and watch me maneuver here we go
knight f5 and once i've achieved this
position
it's very very difficult to actually
lose the game
and so this is the type of setup you
want to be aiming for in rook versus
knight end games
one where the knight can both be an
offensive piece and
a defensive piece so
questions on this one isn't g too good
so g2 is a fine square for the knight
it's a fine square for the knight
but i'm not quite thrilled with it being
in a purely defensive role like let's
say
uh here white is still fine because you
can you know bring the the knight back
out to f5 but let's say you you tried a
more defensive role instead and kept the
knight back here you know all of a
sudden
knight h4 rook a or b3 and
it's like are you really going to be so
safe in this position right
you do have to work pretty hard to keep
all your pieces defended do have to work
pretty hard here
and i can even try to be more clever
with something like
king to f1 and again you're probably
still fine because you have this knight
f5 idea
but if you don't have this knight f5
idea here you could really run into
problems
could run into problems so both
defensive and attacking
and that's the best way to hold with the
knight versus the rook
so bjorn is trying to summarize on the
chat he says a good fortress implies
it's minimizing your weaknesses with a
strong pawn formation use your minor
piece
to shield off the opponent's king so
yeah that's a really critical part of it
here
but the point i'm trying to drive home
is that
the best fortresses also rely on
attacking your opponent's weaknesses and
that's why
putting this knight onto f5 is a great
way
to just ensure you're never going to
lose this game because now
you know i have to keep this rook back
here to try to defend my own pawn
and there's simply no way to even try to
make progress
right like i can pass forever
and what are you going to do here to
make any progress right
let me get checked and you can never
leave this g7 pawn
all right and the chat's veering off
into some other unrelated questions that
i don't want to
cover in this one uh one topic if
everything was shifted down a rank
does white still have a fortress i i
think absolutely yes it
you know it's probably even easier to
hold if all these pawns were moved down
down a rank why is it easier to hold
because there's not these funny ideas
of bringing this king in through the
back rank
okay so with that i want to show you one
last example
this time we're bringing it a little bit
closer to home
this is grand master andrew tang against
the instructor of this class caleb denby
and we're going to see if we can take
what we've learned in building
fortresses
and come up with a good plan
against andrew tang here so let me
jump forward a long long ways
we had queen and rook versus queen of
night which is a little bit different
but at the end of the day we see these
two pieces come off the board we need
four check queen takes and rook takes
and now black to move can you guys
construct a fortress here so obviously
things are
quite a bit different than they were in
our three versus two or
three versus three but still taking what
we've learned
we once you know a knight that's both
offensive
and defensive we want the knight to
cover the king's entry points
and we want to target our opponent's
weaknesses with all these things in mind
black to move here can we come up with a
fortress idea
so general gaming is asking can you only
make a fortress with minor pieces versus
like a rook or a queen what if your
opponent has more than one piece
so i'm using the idea of a fortress
pretty loosely here
you know um i think
the the technical term is a position
where like you know you shuffle back and
forth forever and
you know nothing goes wrong so here i'm
using it to mean sort of
some kind of balance where white isn't
able to make any more progress some kind
of drawing idea and
obviously those exist in in many many
end camps
so don't just say one single move give
me
your ideas
long term plans where do all my pieces
belong
with black
if black is going for a draw why not
just a4 then well
a4 white hits the pawn and then you
still need to come up
with a fortress idea a drawing plan
okay so you guys are coming up with a
good idea here for where we want to sort
of plant our
knight you guys are saying you would
love to put this knight
onto the f4 square so for example
something like
e5 you know white plays a move
and knight f4 and i really like this
square for the knight
because you know number one
it's very actively placed it could
potentially be attacking these king side
pawns
and it's also covering a lot of our
weaknesses
in the position and so i really like
this idea
in the game i wasn't really in love with
playing
knight d3 directly because i thought
that after rook takes c6
knight takes f2 uh i really wasn't going
to quite be in time
to plant this knight onto f4 i was also
a little bit worried about things like
rookie 3
in this kind of position when all of a
sudden my knight's future is not so uh
not so determined right it turns out you
can get away with this with black and
play something like knight d1
and eventually route this guy back into
the game but it was a little bit scary
facing over the board so i wasn't in
love with that way of creating the
fortress because
you know white doesn't really have to
let me play e5 and knight f4 but overall
i think that is a great way to continue
so how can we make it work how can we
get this e5 and knight f4 idea
rolling
knight f3 then go knight g5 so that's
another great idea i'm going to go king
g3
knight g5 let's say i just bring this
rook back to e3
maybe even back to e1 but i wasn't in
love with this idea
either and let me explain why not
because this pawn goes to h4
this pawn goes to h5 and i get my knight
to f4
but all of a sudden looking here
um sorry not okay one
b1 and uh at the end of the day
my king is going to get kind of pinned
on this back row
and with this king stuck back here i'm
not
actually certain that i'm going to be
able to
keep white's pieces entirely out
and the reason for that is again going
to be this idea of
zugsvan and the other thing that's kind
of
the problem is that remember
we're hoping to find some position where
our knight is both an
offensive and a defensive piece and in
this case
my knight really isn't an offensive
piece right it's not actually attacking
any of the weaknesses in the position by
the way
you know i i should probably throw this
in at some point
you know we can take these pawns off the
board
and now um now it's the same problem
right my knight
isn't exactly an offensive piece in this
position it still might be enough to
hold
but it is going to be a little bit
tricky uh
with this knight only acting in a
defensive role guarding these squares
you can imagine this king lands on f5
and here it's not so clear if i'm able
to hold with the king invading
and rook g8 definitely being on the
cards
as well could get kind of tricky right
could get kind of tricky
so i wasn't quite happy with that idea
either so
at the end of the day what i came up
with
is to play this move h5 first uh
and why is this going to be so different
well now after gh5
we get the check and exactly as you guys
were saying with the knight f3 knight g5
line previously
but the difference here is that after 96
in knight f4
my knight is going to be very very
useful uh in an attacking role
as well the king ever strays too far
away
i'm gonna be able to capture on h5 and
get rid of my opponent's pieces
and so this is the defensive idea i went
for in the game i think your guys ideas
were
pretty reasonable as well i think they
might have worked out but this
was the fortress idea i adopted in the
actual
game let's see what andrew tried to
break it down he goes rook a8
right back to e6 and i have this nice
check as well to bring the king back
from f5
come into f4 and we were repeating
so andrew eventually plays h6 now of
course i simply take
and my knight once again is excellently
placed on f4
guarding the entry points and attacking
white's pawns as well
in the game andrew checked a little bit
and then went for h6 because there's no
other way to comfortably hold on to the
pawns
and after uh those pawns were given up
this position is pretty hopeless for
white to try to win so andrew
sacks the rook on f6 and we draw
the chess game so the point i really
want to hammer home here
is you want your fortress to have your
knight in an offensive role
as well as defensive that way you know
you're not
suffering for 50 long moves because your
opponent simply has to give you
the pawns back in order to try to make
any progress
and your life is going to be much much
easier so hopefully you guys learned
something from these night end games
stemming from that one game in the grand
chess tour paris
event it was a lot of fun watching this
paris event and hopefully
you know you guys learned something
about rooks versus knights in today's
class
uh be sure to stick around we've got
grandmaster dennis borosch coming in in
just
a minute or two here uh but for now
that's all i have for you guys tonight
as always thank you so much for watching
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you
next time
you